This is San Marcos, Texas.
Over a century ago,
the United States
Fish Commission
dug a well plunging 188
feet into the earth
right at the heart
of the city.
And when they did, water
rushed to the surface
at thousands of
gallons a minute,
flushing out dozens of
undiscovered creatures
from the depths below.
These animals had never
seen the surface.
Nor would they,
because all of
them were blind.
Perhaps the strangest-looking
animal in this catch
was a species dubbed
Eurycea rathbuni,
now known as the Texas
blind salamander.
Upon discovery, herpetologist
Leonhard Stejneger
described them as such:
Narrator: These unusual
conditions are contained
to a specific 26-mile
stretch of caves
in the Edwards Aquifer,
an extensive underground
layer of rocks.
It's the only
place in the world
this species of salamander
has ever been recorded.
So, how did these caves create
the "profound differences"
in these salamanders'
appearance?
In other words, how did they
end up looking so weird?
To answer this question,
we have to go back in time.
Way back.
Tom Devitt: Take the dates
with a grain of salt,
but we think that
this group split off
from its most recent common
ancestor probably around
somewhere between 10 and
15 million years ago.
Narrator: And geologists
estimate that the aquifer
had been hundreds of millions
of years in the making.
During the Jurassic period,
some 200 million years ago,
the area was occasionally
covered in shallow oceans,
but when the area was
dry and exposed to air,
the rocks were eroded by
weather to make porous caverns.
Eventually, a shallow basin
of water and sediment
covered the land.
Then that basin dried up.
But rainfall continued
to eat away at the earth
to create the deep fissures and
caverns inside the aquifer.
Scientists like Devitt think
that as the climate
became more arid,
some salamanders crawled
beneath the surface,
seeking
refuge in the cool and stable environment
of the Edwards Aquifer.
And over the course
of millions of years,
these salamanders adapted to
the aquatic subterranean caves
by evolving
certain features,
like blood-red gills
outside of their body,
while losing others,
like their eyes.
Living in complete darkness
alongside prey that
was also blind,
the salamanders simply
didn't need to see,
and energy used for sight
would only be wasted.
Today, only two small black
dots just under the skin
remain as evidence
of eyes past.
Those dots likely only detect
if it's light or dark out.
This use-it-or-lose-it
type of evolution
also applies to their
silvery white skin.
Skin pigmentation
usually protects animals
from the sun's UV light
and serves as camouflage
from predators,
but both of those are nonissues
for the blind salamanders,
who don't have to worry
about the sun or predators.
These small,
spindly salamanders
are at the top of the food
chain in this ecosystem,
feeding on various
crustaceans, like shrimp.
And even though they can
go months without eating,
when a potential
snack does swim by,
several features help
them capture their prey.
One is a special adaptation
similar to the lateral
line found in fish,
which detects vibrations
in the water.
The salamanders'
sensory cells respond
to changes in water
movement and pressure,
letting them know
what direction
and how fast their
meal is moving.
Another helpful feature
is their large head,
which fits 10% to
15% more teeth
than surface salamanders.
More teeth means
a deadlier bite,
which is crucial if
you come by prey
only a few times a year.
Danté Fenolio: All of those
things are characteristics
that help you survive
in a very, very
challenging environment,
so that's why they look
the way that they do.
Narrator: Fenolio is
one of the lucky few
who've seen these elusive
salamanders up close.
Last year, his team at
the San Antonio Zoo
bred Texas blind salamanders
for the first time in a lab,
and they've repeated their
success four more times.
They're aiming to protect
the species from extinction,
since the salamanders have
been endangered since 1967.
Two main things threaten the
Texas salamander's survival.
The first is contamination
from wastewater runoff.
This is a big issue,
because the Edwards Aquifer
is a so-called karst aquifer,
which means it's made of
soluble rock like limestone.
Any pollution on the surface
can rapidly seep into and
contaminate groundwater.
Wastewater typically
holds tons of nutrients,
which fuels the
growth of algae.
When the algae decompose,
this process sucks
oxygen from the water,
leaving less oxygen for
our sensitive salamanders.
The second threat is
a loss of habitat.
This happens when rainfall
cannot adequately replenish
the water that people take,
and this threat is real.
The aquifer serves
several cities,
including San Antonio,
one of the fastest-growing
cities in the nation
and the largest
city in the country
that relies entirely on
an aquifer for its water.
So while being able to
breed the salamanders
is a good first step towards
one day building up colonies,
the animal may be
confined to labs
if they have no
home to return to.
Devitt: You know, in
areas where there's been
hundreds of feet of
groundwater depletion,
we've almost certainly
already lost species to that,
but we just don't
know about it,
because we're still
describing new species
from the aquifer
all the time.
Narrator: Devitt's team
is using new tools
to suss out blind
salamander populations,
such as a method that
analyzes water samples
for traces of the
animal's DNA.
He and his collaborator
recently discovered four
new related species
in the aquifer.
For now, scientists say
that these salamanders
can hang in there,
as long as the only home they've
ever known stays constant,
but that's an
increasing challenge
as more people
move to the area.